hey guys welcome to the third episode of
things you didn't know I'm seriously
running out of things to talk about and
this will probably be the last episode
of this series but I still managed to
get a good list so as usual is the rules
if I teach you something new in this
video you are legally obligated to leave
a like if you knew everything dislike
the video don't feel guilty so number
one did you know that if you remove the
abyss walker' ring while you're fighting
the four kings that you'll get a unique
death animation it also says you were
taken by the abyss when you respawn at
the bonfire number two an easy one wrath
of the gods and force can deflect spells
if timed correctly number three another
easy one but many people don't realize
the significance of these statues when
you get cursed in the game
your statue appears in someone else's
world that's what these are number four
a while ago the developer mentioned that
it was possible to skip ceaseless
discharge there's so much lava that have
just looked impossible but it's true if
you have enough vitality enough healing
items and enough practice you can roll
across the edge of the lava this is
commonly used in speedruns I suck at it
though as you can see number 5 another
thing confirmed by the developers is
that the butcher's are in fact female
yup that's a woman number 6 if you
immediately go through the valley of the
drakes and avoid the first encounter
with the Hellkite drake then it will
never appear on this bridge by the same
token you can also trigger the first
encounter with a phantom allowing you to
get a different view looks pretty
[ __ ] cool number 7 gwyndolin has tits
number 8 if you hear the bell ringing in
the undead church then it means that
someone has defeated the gargoyles and
rung the bell in their own world number
9 you can cut off the centipede demons
tail but that's not the only thing did
you know that its tail will grow back if
you leave it a few minutes he makes this
strange sound when it grows back as you
can see I managed to cut and regrow the
tail five times and a head five tails
scurrying around while I fought the boss
he stopped growing tails after the fifth
one I don't think my framerate could
handle them anymore anyway
and number 10 last but not least this
one blows people's minds for some reason
it's a few things to do with the orange
soapstone if you stand over a message
and press select you can vote on orange
soapstone messages and while we're on
this topic did you know that the image
for a message changes depending on how
many votes it has so many of these are
never seen since it's rare to see over
100 votes no votes on a message means it
will show oscar of astora up to 100
votes displays the undead Merchant 101
to 200 displays solaire of astora 201 to
300 shows Dom Hall of Xena 301 to 500
shows the darkmoon knightess and over
500 votes shows the primordial serpent
if you've ever seen a message with over
500 votes let me know I always leave
this message but apparently no one gets
it so that's it I hope you learned a lot
and if you did leave a like but stick
around if you want to get a piece of art
commissioned for free so I've been
working with an artist called coleus
Duvall's
and he made this awesome banner for my
channel since I had to switch over to
one channel design recently it's likely
that you see his work in some future
thumbnails as well anyway the art he
does has a really cool unique style so I
recommend checking out his tumblr all
his work is posted there and it's likely
that a fair bit of Dark Souls related
content will be posted if you follow him
on tumblr collage will choose one lucky
person over the next week to have a
design of their choice made for free
anything you like whether that's your
favorite NPC your YouTube avatar
anything so click the first tumblr link
in the description make an account if
you need to and follow him then make
sure you send a message saying that I
sent you or even just follow him because
he makes great art because it's always a
great thing to support people who create
content for our community
you
you